uh 49.
what was that like
interesting so I was just like 21 at the
time yeah it was a good experience does
the woman feel different at that age a
lot different yeah how
I don't know because I'm not that age
yet so on enough
I don't know if it was because I was
young but I'd say it's just a level of
assurance
you know I've kind of dated around that
age and I would say they're just more
interesting like they have a lot more
life experience and it's a different
kind of relationship they're like your
guider like your Mentor more no for me
it was more like cougar Vibes
you're just taking advantage of a 21
year old yeah and what was your benefit
in that just the reassurance you felt
like Mommy mommy
there's a bonus points in it it's like
it's starting to go into a principle at
the time I mean
yeah I've done that before as well like
when I was in my early 20s I went out
with a I was seeing a woman who was like
mid-30s like maybe like my age now like
34. and um for me the benefit was she
was so
emotionally mature and she knew herself
and there was like this confidence in
her and like I'm not
I wouldn't say I'm the most I'm
I find it difficult to deal with just
insecurities and the idea of making
your insecurities something someone else
has to wrestle with and that's just a
part of a relationship we all do it but
I feel like with her she had dealt with
it wrestled with it and had coping
mechanisms to like pull her through it
and there was so much I learned from her
in that regard of like okay this is what
it looks like when you kind of take care
of your own [ __ ] as well okay yeah when
you take care of your own [ __ ] and so it
was kind of like um it was a really good
experience in that regard for me I think
for her it was like one question yeah
relationship work out like why did you
end up leaving oh because like dude I
think like I I think for her it was
there was a bit of a play aspect to it
like she didn't take me that seriously
and to be fair I wasn't too big I wasn't
to be taken seriously at that age or
time but um we Vibes really well and she
I think even just the idea of what a
woman can contribute to your life
outside of being beautiful and looking
good like just being stimulated mentally
like by her and her life experiences
like you said like it kind of shaped
what I look for dating going forward can
I say something quickly oh God
I'll let you go so basically
as a woman grows older maybe past the
age of like 26 27 they start to have a
better mentality less insecurity less
headaches a bit more maybe grounded in a
bit more self-sufficient when it comes
to emotional stability and yet we're
trying to say that it's easier maybe
perhaps or better for men to go for 19
year olds we're women over 30 generally
are just way more calm yeah anyone over
30s well I'm excited about 20 30. so I
to answer your question I actually don't
think it's just a women thing I think
it's everyone but I think as you develop
and you grow you become more sure of
yourself so now I'm right for the
picking type of thing yeah maybe for
some people I'm not saying everyone in
their 20s is immature or not ready or
whatever but I think generally speaking
in your 20s you're trying to figure it
out in your 30s you know who you are
because you know yourself and you've
learned to like yourself and you've
learned what you're struggling with yeah
I think when you reach that age you just
had so much experience and I'm just
saying like as for me I don't want to
experience your experience so I wouldn't
me personally I wouldn't take anyone
over that age seriously because you come
with a lot of baggage and me personally
if I'm gonna take you seriously in in if
you're like 20 years plus more than me
you you you have a lot of experience
that you're gonna compare me to so if I
lack in one field you'll be like in the
back of your mind you'll be like oh but
when I was dating so and so he used to
buy me all these gifts I'm used to
getting these so it's like I'm not
really trying to go through all that
makes sense how old are you again I'm
20. yes you like when I was your age I
used to feel guilty like if I was
dragging it on for too long because I
feel like you know what I don't I can't
see this long term because of the age
Gap and then I feel guilty like dragging
it on because I feel like I'm wasting
your time do you guys feel like older
women
um okay I had a guy tell me once that if
he dated a girl under the age of 25 he
didn't have to worry as much about that
because she wasn't like dying for a tip
for commitment but if she was over the
age of 25 like they want to settle down
like they want to lock you down quicker
would you say that's true yeah 100 no
all right same no no no no
yeah guys wait wait I'm asking the guys
because they date women so I mean to be
fair I think I think when it comes to
all the women right and I just think
from my experience like when I I like no
I did long term seriously but obviously
you know back in the day your boy had a
little sprinkler around the field but um
one thing
I was I was I was sprouting very early
from 16 onwards but one thing I realized
about
um these uh older women is that it
it's kind of the more on the I I don't
see it on the side where they take it
seriously because once they see a
younger guy they don't usually see me as
a serious candidate as for a long-term
relationship they just want some quick
action and they just want to feel young
again you know what I mean so like I
know when I used to get in those um
situations the fact that
since I was so young and I guess the way
how I would compliment them make them
feel make their bodies feel like there's
a Temple they they they live off of that
stimulation because I'm I'm overly
praising them in such a sense so the
fact that I made them feel younger they
know that I'm not going to get this as a
long-term relationship and I made that
clear from the start but they just
really enjoyed the fun they was getting
a little bit like that and I think the
the common denominator of every story is
that you were young and in your 20s in
your early 20s so I think that shows a
level of manipulation was maybe they're
like they know that you're young and
naive and you're like latch on because
it's fun you know
no no
but like they know you're young and like
like you're impressionable yeah you'll
enjoy the validation of being with them
almost like because like no one said oh
when I was in my like late like when I
was in my uh like late 20s or early 30s
I was with someone that was like 50
because because you know yourself better
and you know that that's not something
you could maybe commit to so who who has
manipulated him or her no like not
manipulator but like are you as your
younger so if you don't know yourself as
well maybe so like you're kind of like
oh like this older person likes me like
oh like that's cool like I I think that
might be slightly different because I
think I think when in the woman's
perspective because she's the younger
one and she's the older guy maybe yeah
maybe from my perspective I know that
when I was in that stage trust me I just
know I wanted to release
yeah I didn't feel manipulated I
personally
I have a question for you guys
is it wrong
for what age do I want to do a 32 year
old man to date an 18 year old no nope
no I judge him for it okay if anyone
says raise your hand if you think yes
all right I'm gonna raise my hand no I
need a yes or no yes or no come on
everyone grows up at different ages okay
it depends okay
what depends what she's listening she
looks I don't know an 18 some of them
look like they're 18 when they're 13.
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible